Dave 35 the general election campaign is
not just ed miliband who's got his own
tablet stone of truth I've got 12 his
might be carved minds in crayon his is
about promises that he thinks that
politicians should make should be making
set in stone and put in the damn street
garden mines in crayon I has the numbers
that might matter on Thursday night
Friday morning 326 you know that's the
normal signify of a majority in the
House of Commons but that looks unlikely
from the projections that we're seeing
so how about three to three if you take
off gin fan who don't sit in the House
of Commons you take off the speaker 323
might give you a working majority again
unlikely from the projections that we're
seeing perhaps it will change both big
parties still say that they can get a
majority so they were left with sort of
like 300 as a kind of secondary winning
mark I mean if either party gets to 300
they'll probably say that they can
fairly easily win a run a minority
government but again that still looks
above where most projections have the
two major parties so i'm looking for
around 290 and i know that people in the
major parties are also looking at around
290 as a mark for where I of the two big
parties because think about their leader
becoming Prime Minister so that's my
stone tablets of truth not as big as
their Miliband's but no less important